I just got sent this big beautiful box
from asgard's wrath 2 which you guys may
have seen at this year's game awards am
so beyond excited to show you this
trailer for asgard's wrath too you know
that Loki in the game is voiced by Matt
merer which is exciting in itself but
you know what else is exciting box nail
death segue okay let's open
it so I got several of these like giant
actually very good quality posters with
some really really cool game on and oh
my gosh you guys have been so excited
about this a meta Quest 3 I am a
hardcore VR user and I have been so
excited to get the quest 3 oh my gosh
here it is in all its Glory plus the new
controllers which I've not had a chance
to try yet they're so light I'm going to
try to actually start making some VR
content I know I talk about it all the
time but I rarely do any gameplay so why
don't we start this weekend with Adar
wrath 2 which is free for a limited time
if you purchase a meta Quest 3 a very
big thank you to them for sending thiso
I'm so excited to try it out